this is the symphony of the seas on
eleven hundred eighty eight feet long
eight thousand eight hundred and eighty
person eighteen deck seven
beast of a cruise ship that makes the
Titanic look like a kayak it cost 1.4
billion dollars but cruise ships only
lasts about 25 years 25 years of
constant cleaning and maintenance plus
an enormous amount of food fuel fees and
employees but tickets can cost just 60
or 70 dollars a day
cheaper than most retirement homes and a
bit more fun
so making profit and quite a bit of it
means optimizing everything from a
ship's flag to its precise schedule like
Airlines the business of cruising is one
of low margins at extreme scale Cruise
Lines are experts at finding clever ways
to save money
Norwegian cruises would even sail 1,100
miles into the middle of nowhere to
avoid fines they run a very tight ship
[Music]
cruises can be long short salty or not
but they all fall under three basic
categories mainstream cruise lines
optimized for scale they sell lots of
tickets or not a lot of money sometimes
even at a loss the average ticket sells
for twelve hundred and ninety three
dollars but cost the company even more
in food fuel wages marketing and lots
lots more if everyone left their wallet
at home these cruise lines would go out
of business but the average person
spends four hundred and twenty nine
dollars on board they're the perfect
captive audience when your only choices
are pepsi or sea water they can pretty
much guarantee your purchase casinos
spas shopping and drinks are key to
making profit and why you can't bring
your own and since everyone walks from
cabin to dining room at least once a day
that's where they place lounges bars and
casinos there's no avoiding them premium
wines are just the opposite they make
most of their money upfront the no
screaming kids on board tax means they
can spend more time in ports and luxury
ships may only hold a few hundred
passengers but each pays more than
enough to make
the difference all three categories
serve very different markets so a good
company catches them all which is why so
many brands are owned by just two mega
corporations Carnival owns Holland
America princess piano and Costa even an
airline at one point and Royal Caribbean
on celebrity and as Ameri this way
something like Costa Concordia doesn't
damage the rest of the company's
reputation when a ship reaches the end
of its life they can just hand it down
to one of their other brands with lower
standards and a cruise ship is a
vacation machine but it can never take a
vacation November to April is when cold
Americans escape to the Caribbean but
keeping that many ships there all year
round would be extremely costly
so is moving around empty ships from one
region to another so they don't when
Caribbean ships switch to Europe in
April they sell repositioning tickets a
one-way two-week cruise from Florida to
say Amsterdam this way the ship is
always making money and when one cruise
ends the next begins turnaround day is a
miracle of coordination in less than
half a day six thousand people exit the
ship and a hotel restaurant a theater
laundromat and theme park clean and
reset as if nothing ever happened when
the ship arrives back at port early in
the morning the clock starts ticking
while passengers sleep all their luggage
must be carried ashore meanwhile trash
is dumped crew members switched fuel
pump and a Costco of food and supplies
loaded onto the ship seventy thousand
eggs three thousand gallons of soda and
fifteen thousand pounds of potatoes by
10:30 passengers are gone and hundreds
of housekeepers rushed to clean all
three thousand rooms then paperwork
needs filed maintenance performed towel
animals folded and lunch cooked by mr.
Fieri all before new passengers arrive
at one by five o'clock the ship is on
its way whether you're on it or not
because the sooner it reaches
international waters the sooner the
casino can start making Bank
gambling is already very profitable but
especially when it's unregulated
so don't go overboard ocean water is
pumped in desalinated and
sent to rooms which because surface area
is so limited are mostly interiors but
the real moneymakers are suites and
balconies so profitable that some ships
have fake windows with virtual views and
the least desirable lower decks are
reserved for the crew there's one for
every 2 passengers but you'll never see
them off-duty they work long hours for 3
to 12 months at a time and they have to
stay in their quarters when not working
and that's because a cruise ship can
register in any country whose labor laws
it prefers most ships fly a flag of
convenience usually Panama or Liberia
saving millions in wages
pretty handy it's why you might have a
Barbadian maitre d or latvian
housekeeper but never a pricey american
the only problem is the passenger vessel
services act of 1886 it says no foreign
vessel shall transport passengers
between ports in the United States a
cruise can take passengers from America
to another country and then
coincidentally those same people back to
America but never directly between
American ports so short Pacific cruises
often stop in Ensenada it's only 50
miles from the US but on a 6000
passenger cruise it saves 1.8 million in
fines but for cruises to Hawaii they had
to get creative every week Norwegian
cruise ships going to Hawaii
would take a four-day 1135 mile detour
to a tiny atoll with no running water or
electricity called Tehran but because
they technically step foot and the
Republic of Kiribati a done hundreds
and then Norwegian built the pride of
America because it's registered in the
US it can avoid the detour but it's
subject to American labor laws which is
why many cruises to Hawaii are more
expensive meanwhile no port wants to be
the next tab or on so they fight to
attract cruises cruise lines sell local
activities for high commissions and port
fees are passed on to passengers but
ideally passengers never leave company
property
so until 2096 Walt Disney owns a small
island in the Bahamas where they take
their cruises called castaway Key and
now other cruise lines are doing the
same it's every company's dream from the
moment you step on board until you leave
10 pounds heavier you're under
magic spell but that's also the beauty
of a crews total convenience the last
thing you want to do on vacation is cook
or clean or remember passwords traveling
in general is hard enough
much less remembering airline hotel and
other passwords sitting by the pool
lemonade in hand and surfing the net is
the last time you should need to
remember your passwords dash line stores
fills and can even generate those
passwords for you anywhere in the world
across all your devices so you can make
them as secure as you want without
having to remember basically dash line
brings the convenience of a cruise to
your passwords using one password for
everything just isn't secure and if you
do what you're supposed to do and make a
long complicated password you'll never
remember it do you want to get into your
account or do you not want to be hacked
those are terrible options and what
makes dash lines so great it works on
pretty much every platform and it's not
some big complicated thing you have to
setup it just works if it finds that one
of your accounts is ever compromised it
sends you a notification so you can
change your password for a ton of sites
dash line can even change your password
for you with one click of a button I
can't tell you how convenient that is
why not make your life easier your data
is worth it click the link in the
description and use the code youtube'
2018 no spaces for 10% off the already
very affordable premium plan or try it
completely free
[Music]
[Music]